pensavo che questo giorno non sarebbe
mai arrivato perché come giovanni non ce
ne sono
incredibilmente la tiny perché era
appunto quello che su quelli che hanno
fatto lo nei board sono decisi a fare
una sorta di eldo neighbor 2 chiamato si
sono dimenticati di mettere titolo però
diamo sui new game e vediamo
scegliamo chi essere sinistra non ho
capito se bello però dalle scritte mi
piace come hanno descritto la persona
sotto il pieno di dettagli utili e lo
guest si chiama perfetto lo meno male
che ci hanno messo qua non nel menu
perché era troppo dispendioso scriverlo
però vabbè non giudichiamo un gioco dal
menu questo lo dico sempre ragazzi
quindi vediamo di cosa si tratta
ecco come infatti sta partendo da dio
finché incredibile ma per inter agazzano
con tutti questi sono le colpe stavo
fosse un gioco a sé stante che non puoi
fare seguendo invece puoi farlo
addirittura con due personaggi da
scegliere cioè incredibile famoso non è
citato ragazza
il successo perché stanno andando le
macchine del fango un problema tutto una
intro cioè fatto veramente bene scrive
la demo ovviamente perché ancora non è
uscito questa è una demo non riuscito
ancora ufficiale ma vedremo è partito
bellissimo
la partenza è stata di quanto la fifth
no stavo solo non solo vedere che lascia
dietro sé tipo slider man c'è ma ragazzi
bellissimo è fatto veramente bene va
bene ragazzi ora nello guest erano to
play this game però posso buttare la
mappa non promette bene 3 sembra un
horror che lo neymar non è un horror è
un gioco strano giudizio buongiorno mi
scusi stavo cercando società ma che hai
un becco al posto della faccia sei un
corvo grosso con le braccia mi scusi
senta e facciale gut non ha gli occhi
questo dire veramente orribile ma va
bene e va vado di farci cazzi miei che
forse è meglio e andiamo di quei ragazzi
ci penso stavo cercando di capire dove
siamo finiti effettivamente nonché la
macchina nomi funzioni ma un santo di
dio io via via via fuori dalle balle e
non mi piace su mostri ha via via dovrei
sentire dei passi se mi si avvicina
troppo credo spero vedono un'ansia
totale dove esattamente stiamo mi guardo
indietro galati perché ci aprono economy
viene attestata che fa male punge il
becco e un becco d'un metro quindi un po
male mi fa c'è una casa con un albero
che si è schiantato sopra va bene la
porta è chiusa delle chiavi posso usare
le chiavi in otto le tette polso
ricorrendo anche quello vecchio dic il
software che cacchio di o ecco perfetto
dove al telefono qualche pronto vodafone
vestiti arti capelli quantità trucchetto
start di shift check the top of the
mountain
ho appena visto il mio personaggio entra
in una casa a rispondere al telefono e
poi trovare una scritta che dice cerca
la cima della montagna
ok no perché effettivamente io se entro
in un posto del genere c'è uno al
telefono a caso il mice guarda sopra la
montagna la prima cosa che faccio è
levarmi dal qatar facciamo che non c'è
niente nell'armadietto cieco c'è un
lucchetto però non lo posso utilizzare
non ho capito se diversamente dal
neighbor qua e metti cielo un kinder
cereali non ho capito se effettivamente
appunto sto dicendo e se gli oggetti che
trovi effettivamente perché lo neighbor
è fatto in modo da trovare oggetti dopo
che userà i per porte e già trovate
un'ora fa quindi io non so se devo fare
dei giri particolari per ritrovare la
chiave di soggetto non alta non ne ho
idea
comunque tutto ciò preferito utilizzare
l'estintore perché mi sentivo abbastanza
protetto possono poi riprendere
l'estintore come cacchio fatto perchè
affetto
ok siccome non ho capito
stavo dicendo siccome non ho capito come
si sbuccia tra gli oggetti e gli devo
prendere in un certo ordine
lo promette bene la montagna ma andiamo
sulla montagna non ho capito come faccio
a cominciare gli oggetti se non
lanciandoli cioè per prenderla torcia
devo lanciare un estintore perché sono
equipaggiarla prove ma che o c'è chi
tira testata le macchine che è orribile
sono ragazzi via via mi piace stare qua
se troppo c'è quanti siete
cosa portate oddio santo ma che facciano
no ragazzi e la cosa fin qui da noi
abbiamo mai visto né aprite aprite la
porta ma la ma c'è una persona normale
il suo gioco
mi scusi ma donando ti seguo prezzo di
culo
vieni qua 2bite incrocio tutto l'istinto
rinfaccia massiva funk una catapecchia
mi scusi mi sa che s'è incazzato non si
è cadenzata correre devo andare anch'io
in cima mi insegni come si fa per favore
o sei tu quello brutto che il gas ma
dove si starà non c'è niente lì c'è un
po di gioco in questo balbi ragazzi
allora è saliamo vediamo se riesco a
salire con queste travi perfettamente a
norma sulla metro cioè con la metro
sulla funivia con la minchia che mi
sembra più una metropoli
no dico m perché in nello neighbor c'era
la metro dentro a casa e sono salito di
sopra forse da quali scala vivaci anche
senza l dive di mamma mia
un fenomeno proprio lui trova il modo di
arginare l'ostacolo
o anche tirato la corrente del lavoro
mai nessuno fa
no
ho alimentato qualcosa o che ne so
una parte
e compagni
rivera 70
a passare
la ferrari sulla m
una donna quale delle due scelgo credo
questa perché è la più 9 ma che sfiga ma
l'altra per caso funziona
dove ci sono due ma non pensate di
questa è la
la sveglia che è successo ma che cosa no
ragazzi non ho capito un cazzo
ok non ho capito non fa niente acqua ci
posso mettere i miei oggetti posso anche
riprenderli figo e tutto questo
l'estintore signore mi sa che cielo
nella seconda mano non so proprio come
sparito il sì però il sempre da antonino
mi servì a niente le torce si sono
scaricate tutte e due tranne questa
questa funzione resto no perché si è
riavviato il livello credo
no perché ve lo spiego io pensavo fosse
impossibile fare un qualcosa di più non
sense di dirglielo nei board non
sbagliavo c'è stato secondo si capisce
veramente una sega di quello che sta
succedendo
minchia che infarto ma ti pare ma come
ti permetti ha visto sorpassare
eccolo perché forse ci riesco
sono bravissimo sono incredibile non c'e
neanche avuto con cene bene basta
utilizzare la fisica ragazzi è stato
veramente facile il timer che ogni tanto
vi compare in alto a destra e il timer
del 6 aprile ha portato ammazzo aiuto
aiuto aiuto molto avvicinati chi una
lanterna nel becco che succede qua
vabbè mentre questi fanno i cavoli loro
prove delle scola significare inside de
paulis tipo così very nice my girl però
non ci passo come possono i dossi porto
lemonia allora questa chiave il vero sia
prego se bene bene bene bene bene bene
bene ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta una
sega perché non si apre questo però già
aperto sono un tecnico di ascensori
fantastico va bene ho fatto tutto sto
bordello adesso funziona parti le vai di
sopra non si fa un millimetro di
passettino in avanti alla volta madonna
che cosa devo fare
oddio eccolo ce l'ho fatta
ce lo fa si è bravissimo ma cos'è vagale
bellissimo ma cosa se va penso ho fatto
sono un palloncino bellissimo la
propulsione e dove vado è una scienza
deve spingere in avanti in alto
non devo andare io tipo in gravi quindi
ovviamente gli sfiduciati
no mi sono una teglia cacchio e
proponesse come dai sto facendo le cose
giuste parco lemonia è bellissimo va
bene ce l'ho fatta nel senso che no
compro tonnellate di estintori credo
ragazzi mio browser e il mio stint ore
nel mentre spero che video vi sia
piaciuto concludo qua e stato un
bellissimo video che il gioco promette
bene si sa quando uscirà la versione
totale e quindi o mentre miss killo nel
salire con l'estintore
vi auguro una buona giornata ha lasciato
in bambù lazio
[Musica]